[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUS CLASS: Hello, and
welcome to the
Google+ Developers Live.
My name is Gus Class.
I'm a developer advocate
on Google+.
And with me here today
is Cartland.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Hi.
My name is Chris Cartland,
and I'm a
developer programs engineer.
GUS CLASS: And also joining us
by a Hangout is a special
guest, Evan from TuneIn.
EVAN OWSKI: I'm Evan Owski.
I am a software engineer
for TuneIn.
GUS CLASS: So today, we're very
excited to talk about
Over-The-Air Installs.
And this is a really exciting
feature because, for users, it
lets you install with one click
right after you sign up
for a website.
And for developers, it
essentially lets you get free
Android installs, because
users are immediately
converted after sign-up.
So it's most clearly
demonstrated when
you see it in action.
So Cartland's going to show it
to you today, and we'll talk
about how to implement it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Excellent.
So I'm over here on tunein.com,
and as a user
who's signed into Google,
I want to sign
up with this website.
And when I go to Sign Up, you'll
see that they have a
couple options, and the
top one here is
Sign in with Google.
I trust Google to handle my
identity, and I want to use
this website, so I am going to
choose Sign in with Google.
I get the normal dialogue
that we talked about
on last week's GDL.
And the important thing is that
when I click Accept, I'm
going to be signed into the app,
but I'm also going to be
prompted to see a dialogue that
says "would you also like
to install the Android app on
your phone?" And this is
really cool because I didn't
even know there was an app,
and I can already install
it with just one click.
So I'm done.
As a user, this is great, as Gus
said, because I can get an
app without searching
through a phone.
I don't have to find it
in the Play Store.
It's already on my
device right now.
I can see the icon, and I can
start using TuneIn in both
platforms without any effort.
GUS CLASS: So again, you just
signed up for the website, and
then at the conclusion of sign
up, you're asked which device
you'd like to push that app
to, and then, boom.
It's right there.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's it.
It's really easy.
Now Evan, did you have a similar
experience when you
first saw that we had
Over-The-Air Installs?
Did you think that
was a cool idea?
EVAN OWSKI: Yeah, I think OTA
Install was probably the
easiest feature to
get to work.
Pretty much we dropped a data
attribute on our Sign-in
button, and it just worked.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Awesome.
EVAN OWSKI: Spent about a minute
implementing it and 30
minutes testing it, so--
CHRIS CARTLAND: Awesome.
EVAN OWSKI: Fantastic.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
really cool.
Speaking of the implementation,
I can show
through all those
steps right now.
It's going to be really fast,
and we're going to see how
easy it is to get Over-The-Air
Installs to work.
GUS CLASS: Now, Chris, you
did that so fast earlier.
I bet our viewers didn't
even get to see the app
on the Nexus 10.
So can we show that one more
time, just to show people
where that is and maybe
kind of walk that
through a little slower?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Oh, sure.
So on our Nexus 10 right here,
the icon has already appeared
on the desktop.
So this is literally the first
time I've touched the device
after I clicked Sign
in on the Web.
And the TuneIn app is
already available.
I can start looking at the
different radio stations and
do everything else that
I would with the app.
And again, I skipped all of
the steps that were in the
Play Store, and everything
that I
wanted was already here.
GUS CLASS: It happened so fast
and transparently that it's
really difficult just to see it
happen because you sign up,
you click Install with the
device you've selected, and
then it's on that device.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Excellent.
So again, similarly, we're going
to show how fast it is
to get this to actually work.
So on my computer I'm looking at
the APIs Console, which is
where you do all of your regular
configuration for
Google APIs.
What you're going to do is make
sure that you create a
client ID for Android using the
same project that your web
application is using.
So we just choose Installed
Application and
fill out two fields.
One of them is your Android's
app package name, which just
identifies, of course, what your
application is-- the one
that we want to install.
And then the second thing you
need to fill out is the SHA1,
which all you Android developers
know, you can use
the keystore to come
up with the SHA1.
And then you say, Create
client ID.
And then your configuration
is done on the web.
GUS CLASS: So again, so this
configuration here-- the
screen that you're showing--
these are the settings
that are pulled from
Android for your app.
And then the next thing you're
going to show is going to be--
CHRIS CARTLAND: How to actually
make the button do
the Over-The-Air Install.
GUS CLASS: OK.
Awesome.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Great.
So once your Android device is
set up like we've just shown
on the web, all we have to add
is one field, and that's the
app package name.
So if you're using the Sign-in
button markup, there's this
field called
data-apppackagename, and it
says, com.google.andro
id.gms.sample.plus, or
whatever TuneIn's
app would be.
And that's it.
Once you put that
on your page--
as Evan said, that took
about a minute.
What else would you like to
add about that, Evan?
GUS CLASS: Yeah, great.
Actually, let's hear a little
bit more about TuneIn's
integration with Google+.
EVAN OWSKI: Sure.
First, let me introduce
the company.
So TuneIn is the
world's radio.
We have 40 million monthly,
active listeners.
You can listen to 70,000 live
stations from all over the
world, and two million pieces
of on-demand content.
So you should definitely check
us out at tunein.com, and
while you're at it, hit Sign
in with Google and grab our
Android app.
So let me go over some of the
ins and outs of what we did
for our integration.
So I did the web integration,
and my colleague, Cliff did
the Android.
So I'll focus on web.
It was about, I would say, a
two, two and a half week
process to get everything
going.
So we did Sign-in and
Sign-up integration.
We did Share.
We did Moments, so if you're
signed in to your Google
account, it broadcasts
these moments.
So Evan Owski is listening to
Laid Back Radio right now.
And it's kind of a cool way of
letting your friends know what
you're up to, listening
to on TuneIn.
GUS CLASS: Cool.
So you guys are taking advantage
of the app activity
functionality.
And so then as someone listens
to radio, it kind of
continuously writes the things
that they're doing.
EVAN OWSKI: Right.
Right.
So if they tune in to a new
station, if they tune in to a
new program, if they Favorite
something, that all gets
posted in their Moments
stream.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Awesome.
EVAN OWSKI: And, of course, if
they don't want that they can
always disable it.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Right.
And one of things that Google+
Sign-in allows you to do is
give the user control over who
can actually see those app
activities.
EVAN OWSKI: Right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So they're not
necessarily broadcast to
people that they don't want.
They are only given to
exactly who the user
says should see them.
Cool.
EVAN OWSKI: Right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Excellent.
GUS CLASS: Awesome.
Sorry, we totally
interrupted you.
Were you guys doing some work
also with interactive posts?
Because they also kind of go
hand-in-hand with those sorts
of things, like, I'm listening
to this now.
Come and listen to what
I'm listening to, too.
EVAN OWSKI: Yeah, we did
implement Interactive Post as
well, and that was maybe second
to like OTA Install,
probably the easiest feature
to implement.
We had some existing metadata
on our station and program
pages, and Google was able to
pull that information down and
interpret it correctly.
We really didn't have to do any
additional work to take
advantage of that metadata, so
that when you click the Share
button, Share on Google+, you
had all the correct title and
description of the page
and an icon as well.
GUS CLASS: That's awesome.
So you're able to pre-populate,
set all the
things that you want to appear
in that interactive post, and
then the users can selectively
render it to their stream.
That's cool.
So what do you think was one
of the most exciting things
that has happened as
a result of Google+
Sign-in for you guys?
Do you look forward to getting
deeper functionality from this
and additional things you have
that couldn't make it in for
the launch?
EVAN OWSKI: Yeah, there were
a few features that we were
definitely thinking
about including.
One of the features that we
ended up implementing on web
was the calendar integration,
which is awesome because
TuneIn has a ton of live
content, and we have schedules
for a lot of our stations.
And so if you want to listen
to say "Morning Edition" or
even a sporting event-- we've
got March Madness coming up--
and you want to set a reminder
to yourself to listen to it,
you can just add that to your
calendar right from our
Android app.
And that's something we
don't yet have on web.
GUS CLASS: That's cool.
EVAN OWSKI: But yeah, we're very
excited about Sign-on,
because almost everyone who
comes to our site, a lot of
our users, are going to be
signed in already with Google,
and we like to get them to sign
up so that they can get
some of our better features
like Favorites.
And it just removes
that extra step of
having to type in email.
And I know when I go to a new
site, I'm pretty lazy, and I
don't like to have to type in a
lot of stuff to sign up for
an account, so it just makes
it that much easier.
GUS CLASS: Yep, and
additionally, like on mobile,
there's nothing worse than
trying to enter your password
with those little keys, right?
EVAN OWSKI: Oh yeah.
Totally.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so what
did you think about Google as
a position to help
your integration?
Do you think anything we had was
particularly special that
made it great for your
application?
EVAN OWSKI: So we were part of
the launch, and so we worked
pretty closely with
the Google+ team,
and they were great--
very responsive to
our questions.
I think at the beginning there
was a little bit of a scarcity
of-- some of the documentation
was a bit scattered.
But we saw, sort of as the
process went along, the
documentation got a lot better,
got more filled in.
And so I think some of the
difficulties that we might
have had early on when other
companies come in, when other
projects come in and they do
this kind of integration, I
think it's going to be a
lot smoother for them.
And they'll be able to just
jump right in, use the
documentation.
It will be pretty much
out of the box.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, awesome.
And do you have any advice for
third-party developers who are
kind of like you guys, who had
to get-- you know, you got
early access to it and a little
bit more handholding--
any kind of tricks or
recommendations, ways that
guys that are kind of starting
out with this
can save some time?
EVAN OWSKI: Yeah, I would
say definitely
grab the sample app.
The sample app was really
helpful, and a lot of the
examples you can just drop
pretty much copy, paste
verbatim, and they just work.
GUS CLASS: So did you guys start
with the quick-start, or
did you start with
a PhotoHunt?
EVAN OWSKI: What was
the second one?
GUS CLASS: There's PhotoHunt,
which is sort of a showcase
app that shows an actual full
integration like with the
Over-The-Air Installs and it's
got an Android and iOS app and
also a web server.
If you guys didn't
start with--
EVAN OWSKI: Oh, I don't think we
even knew about PhotoHunt.
GUS CLASS: Oh, awesome.
That is the new, new then.
So you found the quick-start
samples to be real helpful,
and they're available for all
the languages that most
developers use, which
is handy.
Cool.
Trying to think what else.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Do you have
any questions from people
online that we can get to?
GUS CLASS: Sure.
The first question that we're
seeing is, some people have
expressed concerns that
Over-The-Air Installs are
hardware dependent.
And Cartland, do you want
to take this one?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so the
Over-The-Air Installs will
work on any phone
with Android--
what's the number--
2.3 or higher.
It's Gingerbread.
So as long as you have that and
you have the Google Play
Store installed, then
it'll work,
which is a lot of devices.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, so there's a
whole lot of Android devices
out there, and yeah, the
hardware dependence is just
kind of-- there's a minimum
version of Android.
So long as your device supports
that minimum version,
then you are good to go for
these Over-The-Air Installs.
Another question is, does anyone
know if the Auth Token
from the Sign-in service can
be used for any other OAuth
2.0 methods Google services,
for instance spreadsheets?
And actually Evan can speak
to this, because they did
calendar integration in addition
to Google+ Sign-in
integration.
Do you want to talk a little
bit about kind of the extra
leg work that you guys had
to do to enable that
functionality?
EVAN OWSKI: So I can't speak
to calendar integration too
much, because we didn't do that
on web, and Cliff would
be a better person to answer
that question for mobile since
he did that side of it.
GUS CLASS: Yeah, sure.
I can actually jump in here
and talk to this.
So there's only two things
that you have to do.
You need to turn on the services
for the additional
functionality that you need.
And then the next thing you need
to do is just request the
right scopes.
When the user clicks the Sign-in
button, they'll be
shown all the scopes that you're
requesting, and they
can control which of them they
will allow access to.
So another question is--
no more questions.
So we actually don't have
anything new to
announce this week.
But we do want to say that it's
really exciting to be
back on to Google Developers
Live, and we look forward a
lot to additional shows talking
about the Google+ platform.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And thank you so
much to TuneIn and Evan for
joining us today.
We had a really great time
talking with you.
EVAN OWSKI: Yeah, it's
great to be here.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yep.
Well, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]